judgment at Nuremburg those words ring  in my ears I was caught I was in New  York and I was called to Los Angeles to  meet Stanley and I was a young actor  than very young and I met Stanley Kramer  the great director and finally I was  hired and I was in this film with with  all these great stars and I met  everybody and it was it was the  monumental moment in my life and still  is it was a great film at a great  experience I cherish the memory of  Stanley Kramer in retrospect it was one  of the great things in my life to meet  all those actors to see them work see  how they worked to have an opinion on  all of them and and to retain that is as  a glorious thing for me and I'm so glad  to be able to say this to all of you  with the memory of that movie and  Stanley will be in my mind forever